tar
[Music]
Yeah
Hmm
[Music] It's
my usual plan, but
it seems that a predecessor has appeared.
I want to get rid of the mountains, but unfortunately I can't take my hands off.
Well, in other words, it's just you,
ah ah ah ah,
I can't help opening
it, talon or soar
yeah
, who
calls me when I retire?  It takes time for you to go, so if you
have a rough
idea of where you're going, it's a costume for me.
Where and what's
So I'm going 2 Jaguar
Wow
wasara
I bought a hunting foot
me
car
yeah yeah yeah me ran ana car yeah yeah yeah car ran me ran yeah yeah yeah [music] car ah ah
ah ah
ah ame
hope  I'm not doing it yeah yeah yeah
tan tan
uh
[music]
Razz is over
Ah,
this is also the place where I've cleaned
up